[Musique]
la meilleure série française de la neige
d'année d'air
c'est la première fois que je m'attelle
un projet qui fait autant l'unanimité
c'est ce succès là je pense que personne
ne pouvait l'imaginer pour atteindre un
score de 20 millions de visionnages
c'est un phénomène d'une vraie
validation on était comme des dingues
quoi c'était c'était c'était fou alors
qu'est ce que ça fait de faire la série
qui fait le plus gros carton l'histoire
de canal et à aucun moment tu t'attends
à un tel succès il à aucun moment que ça
y est les gens étaient en train de dire
c'est la série du confinement validé est
et la bande son de cette période j'ai
l'impression que ça tirait elle a été
plus faire avec le rap que contre le rap
ou à côté du rap c'est là où tu t'y
bloqué mission accomplie et tu peux voir
tranquille ce qu'on a vécu pendant ce
confinement et la sortie de valider on
va marquer ma vie pour toujours tout
tout tout a changé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'engouement du public qui attendait une
série sage la santé moi même en tant que
spectateur j'aurais voulu voir cette
série qui traite de la musique que
j'aime que j'écoute depuis et depuis je
suis gamin aujourd'hui le rap que ce
soit en france mais dans le monde de la
musique qui dominent tous ces mêmes j'ai
envie de dire le mouvement culturel qui
domine tout et qui est pas eu avant
validé en france une série grand public
sur le rap c'était quasiment une
absurdité
[Musique]
donc dès le tournage on sentait quand
même qui se passait quelque chose de da
c'est cool que ça allait provoquer une
attente quand j'ai vu les équipes de
tournage tout le tout ce qui a été mis
en oeuvre et que ça faisait assez réelle
j'ai dit que ça allait péter avec les
lieux qu'on les lieux dans lesquels ont
tourné tout pour moi y avait aucune
aucune raison ça marche pas après que
c'est ce succès là je pense que personne
ne pouvait l'imaginer
[Musique]
ce rendez compte que nos réseaux sociaux
étaient un peu affolée à chaque fois
qu'on racontait les guest qui rejoignait
le casting a et à la crim à et hamacs
terre à on voit un tel cas on voit un
tel jeu ça buzz est en game où les gens
c'est bon et à l'art de se passer
quelque chose dans tous les rappeurs qui
ont qui ont mis leur notoriété l'espace
d'une journée ou deux tournages au
service de la série once a grandement
contribué à
exciter à rendre le projet
attrayant pour le public et puis pour
être très honnête c'est quand on a
commencé à visionner les premiers
épisodes c'était la cua c'est à dire
qu'on regardait ces épisodes que j'ai
imaginé que j'ai fantasmé depuis 2010
est que j'ai cette série dans ma tête et
et tout était là alors après tu c'est
dans ces moments là c'est toujours
délicat parce que tu ne sais pas si
tu ne sais pas si c'est parce que c'est
ton bébé que tu trouve ça bien ou si
c'est vraiment parce que c'est bien tu
vois est ce qu'il faut c'est que
moi-même quand j'ai regardé et je
voulais voir la suite tant que tu dis ok
d'accord ça fonctionne tu vois preto on
a eu l'impression on à glaçons la
certitude même que la série s'adresse à
elle un public qui dépassait largement
les aficionados
[Musique]
puis arrive la soirée du trianon juste
avant de partir en confinement on savait
évidemment pas qu'elle confinement les
nous tomber dessus quelques jours après
et effectivement c'est une super soirée
un show case avec des artistes qu'on
avait réuni ces artistes qui sont sur la
bo qui était franchement c'était
impressionnant pour un événement comme
ça j'étais sur scène y at il sur scène
est digne sur scène y avait des posters
flic sur scène j'ai fait prison pour
mineurs je crois que c'était trop bien
c'est trop bien c'était la dernière fois
en baisse et interrompu ses vins
concernés je veux dire c'était
incroyable parce que là pour le coup
c'était la première fois que qu'ont
montré les trois premiers épisodes 1 au
public quoi ravir tous les gens de la
profession les gens du game donc la
presse et tous les curieux et beaucoup
de personnes qui pensaient qu'on allait
se planter qui étaient là qui tout le
monde est aussi en attente de savoir ce
que j'ai fait de cette première série
dans le milieu du rap parce que ce que
j'ai tout gâché est ce que parce que
c'est bien on est ce que est ce que les
vrais protagonistes du milieu durable
vont se retrouver dans cette série
toutes ces questions qui
qui qui était parfois un peu difficile à
porter parce qu'il ya un moment où tu
fais une série sur rap il va quand même
falloir avoir les couilles d'y aller tu
vas sur le créneau des virulents sur le
créneau des énervés sur le créneau des
agités des réseaux sociaux où tu sais
que tu vas te faire allumer si c'est pas
donné
et les retours de quoi dépenser manger
une claque c'est un jim disneyland toute
la soirée et surtout je me rappelle du
moment où lorsqu'un pages fait son
premier son premier freestyle à skyrock
que tout le monde applaudit quoi donc à
ce moment là je me suis dit ah ouais
c'est kif les gens ont fait ça ça rit ça
crie ça applaudit c'est anigo rayonne à
la fin merveilleux souvenirs qui va
rester un merveilleux souvenir dans ma
carrière mais je crois pour tous les
gens qui étaient là après tout ça il ya
eu elle confirmant le vrai confinement
ont pas le couvre-feu le confinement n'a
pas le droit de sortir de chez nous on
va vivre la sortie de valider pendant
cette période où tout le monde est
enfermé chacun chez soi le moment où
validé est en ligne dans les minutes qui
suivent c'est une déflagration français
sorti sur my canal c'est n'importe quoi
en fait à partir de ce moment là c'est
n'importe quoi ma vie et elle a plus
aucun sens à quelques gens qui caouette
super lourd du bon ok d'accord mais en
fait toute la nuit ça s'enchaîne en fait
c'est des centaines et des centaines de
tweets de messages privés le premier
épisode était pas terminée déjà on avait
un gros engouement autour de la série
il y avait des gens qui ont regardé la
série deux fois dès qu'elle est sortie
puisque ils ont fait toute la nuit qu'il
ya des gens qu'on finit plus vite que
d'autres donc avait déjà des théories on
a d'autres qui la regarde et une seconde
fois je suis réveillé j'ai vu 800
messages d'insultés ouais pourquoi tu as
tué mounir est pourquoi tu as tu es un
peu hs que c'est toi qui l'a tuée est un
peu grand disque d'or j'ai compris que
ça allait marcher quand comme je
continue à faire de la radio même
pendant confinement on a des écrans à la
radio qui nous balance
tout ce qu'on peut avoir sur les réseaux
sociaux et j'ai vu un nombre de messages
hallucine sur validables vraiment et
quand on s'appelait les uns les autres
les acteurs les producteurs on se
rendait compte que tout le monde était
en train de vivre ce même choc c'est
incroyable je reçois des messages toute
la journée toute la nuit quand je me
réveille je peux pas lire tout ce que
j'ai reçu
ça c'est un souvenir assez incroyable
clément bonjour
moi je pensais surtout au petit pour moi
c'est la première fois qu'ils vont
connaître un succès donc j'aurais aimé
qu'il soit réellement voilà en
contactant porté par la foule quand
je reçois des messages de gens que j'ai
regardé toute ma vie je regardais mon
nombre de followers mehdi doit y avoir
un bug pas personnellement j'avais pas
du tout de followers sur instagram et
plus de cinquante et une personnes sont
venues me suivent du jour au lendemain
que je recevais pas mal de messages de
remerciements carrément à une fréquence
incroyable j'ai le souvenir de poser mon
téléphone cinq minutes et quand je leur
prenait ça y est je ne pouvais même plus
lire tous les messages que j'avais reçu
tellement je recevais des messages
d'amour de plein de gens qui me disaient
que il aimait ce qu'on avait fait que ça
leur avait remonté le moral
quelle surprise
kiffante de se rendre compte que
l'immense majorité des rappeurs et du
milieu du rap valide validé
qu'ils y vont tous deux leur petit tweet
de leur petit snap ce film en train de
regarder la série que quelques temps
après je vois des interviews de rappeurs
que j'adore qui disait j'ai regardé
validé pendant pendant leur confinement
sch par exemple et j'ai kiffé de haut
parce que on trouve des situations qu'on
qu'on a pu voir vivre par des gens ou
même vécu nous-mêmes et tout ça et c'est
sympa quand ce milieu là un moment vient
de voir dix ans franchement chapeau ce
qu'il a fait il a réussi vraiment à
restituer des histoires il il a raconté
nos vies en fait il a raconté nos vies
et sa fille peut tenir pour faire partie
de ce milieu depuis plus de vingt ans
maintenant c'est très rare ce petit
c'est un phénomène et vaut mieux tuer
avec toi chez oméga que contre trois
dans une autre maison on est à plusieurs
millions déjà alors que la série était
sorti depuis quelques jours
et
par là je voulais pas vivre ce moment
tout seul donc j'ai appelé en facetime
chacun des acteurs francky me dis ok là
on c'est n'importe quoi on a battu le
record restauré quel truc
c'est magnifique c'était le premier 5
millions jamais choqué puis ensuite ça a
augmenté de 100 concentré j'ai compris
que c'était quelque chose mais voilà les
chiffres étaient complètement dingue et
tous les jours on est en train de
s'échanger en train de se dire ok 1
million de millions 3 millions en 4
millions 5 millions 10 millions autant
qu'on était là on était comme on était
comme des dingues quoi c'était c'était
c'était fou
je savais que ça intéresserait les gens
je le savais évidemment là ça ça a
dépassé tout ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
c'était l'un des seuls aspects positifs
du confinement savent peut-être permis
d'aller plus vite dans le succès mais je
pense que de toutes les façons le bouche
à oreille se serait installé comme bilal
ça a permis à des gens qui n'étaient pas
forcément touchés par le sujet du rap de
s'intéresser à cette série ça j'y crois
vraiment et ça je pense que c'est dû
essentiellement à l'angle de nos
scénaristes qui ont fait des personnages
et une histoire qui touche tout le monde
au delà du rap tu m'as un quart mais je
crois qu'il peut retirer un choix
ça a été un c'était une bagarre ont
validé c1 c'est faire une série comme ça
c'est c'est beaucoup de travail c'est
beaucoup d'investissement
les trois dernières années de ma vie ont
été consacrés à ce projet j'ai
complètement conscience que ce qu'on a
vécu pendant ce confinement et la sortie
de velde et on va a marqué ma vie pour
toujours tout tout tout a changé c'est
ma vie privée c'est rapport à la
célébrité c'est ce que j'ai envie de
faire c'est financier c'est mon aura
dans les médias ces deux planètes qui
solide et validé derrière john juste
juste après
le forum c'est une foule je m'attendais
pas du tout à tout ce à quoi donc on
peut dire que ma vie elle a un petit peu
changé depuis aujourd'hui maintenant les
policiers quand je m'arrête ici pour me
demander quand est-ce qu'elle sera
saison 2 pour demander de ramener franck
au commissariat les tic comme ça hop et
truc qui m'arrivait pas avant
c'est aussi une victoire c'est aussi une
victoire pour moi je crois qu'ils
n'osaient même pas rêvé de ce qui leur
est arrivé ils viennent un casting qui
tentent leur chance ils sont pris ils
font de leur mieux on sait pas ce que ça
va donner puis la série devient ce cas
tu viens on est lié à vie par sa
aujourd'hui validé c'est nous le succès
qu'est
qui a eu autant de sens on le prend
vraiment personnellement et ses
magnifiques pas l'idée d'un taux légal
trop de problème pas de mine sur le
de nîmes
j'ai toujours
demande
c'est sûr
porter
[Musique]
enfin plus peur
quand on veut
[Musique]